We Begin this half hour with a new tool
in fighting the opioid epidemic nearly 1
million Americans have died from a drug
overdose since 1999. many mainly from
opioids in New Jersey Camden County has
one of the highest overdose and
drug-related fatality rates in the
states CBS News medical contributor Dr
Celine gounder has worn a new treatment
to drug addiction that's showing promise
in that Community Dr counter good
morning good morning Jeff we've learned
it's not enough to use drugs like
naloxone commonly known as Narcan to
reverse someone's overdose we've got to
get them into medical treatment and now
doctors at Cooper Medical in Camden are
trying a novel way to encourage this
thank you
throughout the city of Camden the battle
against the opioid overdose crisis is a
daily fight
for those who live here
how high up and for the First Responders
it's better than it used to be it's
still in the thick of it I would say
paramedic lathe shubar has worked in
Camden for the past three years
paramedic Corey depatry for two it's a
lot of poverty there's a lot of mental
illness that goes on here especially
untreated mental illness in this
population here and a lot of drug
addiction and city of Camden
the pair work for Cooper University
healthcare one of the major Health Care
Systems serving the area on average they
respond to three overdose calls per
12-hour shift EMS director Rick rohrback
they would come in at seven in the
morning they would go out they would
reverse an opioid overdose and by the
end of their shift they were going out
and reversing the same patient with
another opioid overdose within the same
shift within the same shift a level of
demand that EMS medical director Dr
Gerald Carroll also had to navigate in
the emergency room how have you seen
drug use drug overdose change over the
last decade or so in Camden all of a
sudden
half the patient board in the emergency
department would be overdose or
unconscious or drug related problem
which had never been like that over the
past decade overdose deaths more than
doubled
ten thousand deaths per year
75 percent of all drug overdose deaths
involve opioids when the data started
coming out that every overdose we see
has a one in 10 chance of dying in the
next year
that kind of put that all in perspective
for us that's when Dr Carroll and his
colleagues in Camden started their study
with the medication buprenorphine bupe
for short is taken orally to treat
opioid withdrawal and stabilize patients
study found that by equipping ambulances
with this medication and training
paramedics to start patients on it after
Reviving them they could get almost six
times as many people into drug treatment
within the following month but these
conversations can be difficult for First
Responders so they follow a mental
script here's the way we kind of script
it and how we think about it right so
patient overdoses they stop breathing
everyone runs around finally 911 shows
up maybe some Narcan has been given
hopefully because that's getting better
maybe it hasn't we ventilate the patient
with a bag valve mask and patient
breathes and then they start to wake up
all right yes and that used to be where
we finished and this is where it's game
on we're out
they're going to be disoriented they're
definitely not going to feel good and
pretty quickly as they wake up they're
going to wonder where they are realize
where they are and then wonder what's
happened to them why they were not aware
we got you
there you go
you'd be interested in taking the subs
right now yeah get you feeling better
and I think that conversation that piece
the idea that our paramedics tag off if
one's not connecting and then
administering the medicine and all that
happens in less than 10 minutes two tabs
under your tongue all right we're gonna
hang out with you make sure you feel
better if you need more we'll give you
more here open up lift your tongue up
they go right underneath your tongue I
think that kind of scripting really
makes this program work and I think when
paramedics can EMTs think about that I
think they can see how they could do it
too it's not a solution to the opiate
crisis so I don't want to overstate
anything but when patients take it and I
would say it's I think our uptake is
somewhere around 1 in 10 1 in 12 but of
those about 30 to 40 percent make their
first and second appointments and are in
treatment at about 30 days
that comprehensive treatment is led by
Dr Caitlin Baston the head of Cooper
University's Center for Healing what do
you do the first time you meet with them
in the clinic we basically ask what
their needs are that day food clothes
shelter you know community and
engagement and love which is a basic
need and medication if you don't have
your basic needs met it's really hard to
engage well in therapy or work on your
trauma services to help with mental
health housing employment and other
basic needs are also offered here an
all-encompassing revamped approach to
treating addiction we saw paramedics and
EMTs and Frontline workers police
officers nurses you know folks in the
hospital
overdose reversing people giving them
emergency naloxone over and over and
over again and they felt like the
patients were failing but we never give
those patients treatment we just reverse
them it'd be like if someone had a heart
attack and we immediately stabilize them
but then gave them no medicines to
prevent the next heart attack and they
were like weird they had a heart attack
again in 2019 the New Jersey Department
of Health approved a 250 thousand dollar
Grant to fund paramedics to carry an
offer bupe on emergency calls what kind
of pushback did each of you get it's
very easy to give Narcan wake someone up
it's another thing to actually talk to
someone and try and reach them where
they are that's a different skill set
they were like this is not going to work
you know this is hopeless and what I
think really turned the tide for a lot
of them is we we had them spend some
time in the addiction Clinic you start
to see them really as the person that
they are it's complicated how they got
to where they are it's
and there's a lot more that paramedics
can be doing in the field
it's making a difference
mechanism one emergency Call at a time
what are you seeing with overdose rates
in Camden County we actually saw
overdose rates stay stable or go down a
little bit while overdose rates were
still skyrocketing in every other County
in New Jersey but it's not a quick fix
people think if you just get through the
withdrawal you've now treated the
illness but we know there are brain
changes that are chronic that happened
and it it's not just getting through a
draw that treats it you have to actually
be on a stabilizing medicine and then
have long-term recovery for your brain
to heal and the Brain can heal but you
need time what would you say to people
who would say these are just more drugs
that you're giving people it's another
addiction it's a difference between
addiction and a medication or a
treatment right addiction is an out of
control use
and when my patients say aren't I just
trading one drug for another I'm like
yes you're trading one very dangerous
illegal drug that you can overdose on
that causes all these terrible things to
happen to your brain for a safe
prescribed medicine that you can get
from the doctor at a pharmacy and you're
going to live a normal life I would make
that trade any day
this is like game changing yeah it seems
like and I said to you in the middle of
the piece if you think about that 30 to
40 percent that they mentioned that
actually after that first treatment get
to that second moment of potentially
treating this addiction that they've had
that seems huge that's pretty good right
you know 30 to 40 percent of people who
might have we might have failed that
we're actually starting to get into
treatment and you know as they say in
the piece it's not enough to reverse
somebody's overdose that's just step one
right you know it's like making that
diagnosis of a heart attack it's not
enough to do that you really need to get
somebody into treatment does that
emergency treatment also work with other
drugs like heroin fentanyl I mean in
overdose situations so the narcanaloxone
that's the step one piece yes so any of
those drugs that'll help reverse and
wake you up but then you do need to
continue with some other treatment and
what they're using here in the field is
buprenorphine
huge huge huge thanks doctor thank you